hi um I'd like to talk to you about
something that's near to my heart and
that has come close to something else
that is recently near to my heart which
is physics and machine learning so bit
about my background and I started in
physics became a bit more mathematical
physicist and did a PhD became a data
scientist and now I work at Bowery
farming and just shout out we are hiring
for machine learning engineer and a data
scientist but this talk I am giving
today is not in any way representative
of what I do at Bowery farming so just
don't let this be the pool I am more
than happy to talk about all the
interesting things we do at Asbury
because it is in its own right
incredibly interesting and and if you if
you want to follow a little bit more um
if you want to have a bit more reading
material after this talk you can go to
my github and I have some extra stuff
there it's a bit of there so why am i
interested in this well so I come from
physics many-body quantum systems in
particular and I now work as a data
scientist and there have always been
sort of there's always been some inputs
of physics and of course other
disciplines into machine learning but
recently the the noise has sort of amped
up a little bit and I would like to I
would like to talk to you a little bit
about about what sort of that yeah what
that is and what's causing that and what
what this might bring for you in the
future so we know already that
empirically that some deep learning
protocols are really good at solving
some types of problems and you might
think well do we do we need to know
but doing do we need to study this more
we already empirically have such good
results yeah you you can you can try all
these all these things and you know you
can you can just stack them all up on
top of each other and get get great
results but I think it does make a lot
of sense to try to answer the question
of why these things work and let's just
take a step back first it it is in
principle seems like a really hard
problem because there's a lot of data
for example in a classification problem
of an image so that means that there's a
huge number of probabilities so so why
so how would a system that has to look
at all these data points like learn what
it is looking at so let's take tiny
little step into mathematics a principle
they say a neural network can
approximate any smooth function but it
can be very expensive and that's kind of
where I'm going to leave it because what
we actually want to know is why neural
networks that are quite small in the
number of neurons can still model so
many of the things that we are
interested in so one thing that's that
might help us a little bit is the notion
of simplicity so what you see here is a
fractal which looks very complicated but
actually it can be generated by a
relatively simple algorithm another
example is the snowflake algorithm you
can draw snowflakes yourself very easily
by starting with a triangle and then
taking every edge and making a little
triangle on the edge so if you do that a
few times you end up with actually quite
complex looking snowflakes but the
algorithm you used to make this was
really really simple
another example here is where you see on
the right you see something that
actually that we actually see a nature
and on the left is an algorithm that's
produced that same thing looks very
realistic and if the point here is that
if a pattern is really easy to reproduce
it is just very likely for it to happen
in nature you see more examples here so
one idea of why we might find all these
simple patterns everywhere well if
there's a low complexity there are just
so many what symmetries so many ways for
the same thing to appear so that might
make it much more likely for simple
things to appear so let's pause a little
bit with just a bold statement and this
is of course not the endpoint of the
discussion today but I think it seems
reasonable that the world has a
simplicity bias but that's not very
precise so let's put on our physicist
hats for a moment and say you know what
what what other things can we and we
learn from physics can we take from
physics to answer a question here so
object object attention for example
another you know like a very very widely
used widely seen problem has an implied
scale so in the center you see you know
the object that we want to detect the
bicycle and if you zoom in on the right
you see something that doesn't look at
all like a bicycle if you zoom in so
much you have no idea what you're
looking at and on the left you see well
there's actually I promise you a tiny
bicycle there but you know you wouldn't
be able to tell it apart from anything
else so that's clearly not the right
skill to look at and if you were to look
at similar objects like bikes or you
know cats you would again see you know
if you zoom in very much there's no way
you can tell which is which
and if you zoom out a lot they all look
the same physics is also something which
has an implied scale so if you
a magnet that has like a certain type of
behavior at a scale that we can
understand if you were to zoom in into
its constituents you wouldn't
necessarily be able to tell that that's
a magnet just from looking at every
single particle that makes it up what
you need to do is actually zoom out to
just the right scale and to see patterns
patterns emerge emergent behavior that
looks like the kind of behavior that
you're looking for so the way physics
physicists do that is using what we call
the arena normalization group you don't
need to know what that is I'll just tell
you basically what it is you look at a
microscopic theory that the scribes sort
of the individual particles and then you
sort of zoom out and you try to look as
if through blurry glasses at the same
system and then you look at what's the
at what that changes on what the emerge
the new emergent behavior is at that
different scale so for example here you
would combine these individual spins
into super spins and so those are not
actually particles right so they're
quasi particles they don't actually
exists they're sort of the effective
behavior of multiple particles at the
same time and you have a new theory in
terms of those new sort of fake
particles and this step that you do is
you change your parameter oh there
should not be a tilde at the bottom I'm
sorry so you change your parameter in
such a way that's the long-range physics
sort of the things that you know should
not change just because you've put on
blurry glasses that that remains the
same and that gives you a new parameter
that's describing all the interactions
and that basically tells you you know as
you start to zoom out and sort of lose
all the details what remains
so that's yeah so that's what it's also
the coefficients so this coefficient
changes but it changes in such a way
that the macroscopic way that the
macroscopic behavior of the system does
not because you know things don't just
like start falling sideways just because
you know you're zooming out physics has
to physics has to remain the same so we
can keep doing that multiple times and
what we get is sort of a succession of
different sets of parameters that are
describing the physics at different
length scales and you can you can you
can look at all those parameters that
can be very high-dimensional because
basically every every single one of
these J I J's is basically could be a
really long vector of all the of all the
different forces that are present in
your system so let's say for example we
have this like little square letters and
it has one force in one direction one
force on like even rows in one direction
and then another on the odd rows you
want to have it like a little bit
interesting to have like three different
three different types of forces so let's
map out yeah that means we have three
parameters and we start on one point in
that parameter space and after a whole
succession of these like zoom out
renormalization group steps we have
ended up somewhere else in that
parameter space so what we can see from
here is if we zoom out and some
parameter becomes a little bit bigger so
you can see in the J a direction it's
became a little bit bigger we call that
a relevant parameter so basically that
parameter is for some kind of force or
interaction that interaction is relevant
at there long scale because it'll roll
if it's smaller like the b1 it's
irrelevant so basically this is a
feature of the really small
skill behavior that is not that that
just washes away at the at the large
scale and then we have another relevance
parameter Josi became a bit bigger so
what's important is this is to use a
machine learning term unsupervised you
don't tell nature how to behave you just
say alright the way I do this is is
preserving the long-range behavior
because I know that putting on blur and
blurry glasses should not make things
behave wildly differently so in deep
learning this is actually not a new
result at all and but this was quite a
big result when it came out you can
actually use the same the same kind of
technique you you they call it a
restricted Boltzmann machine where you
have a visible layer which would be
let's say your reel spins you have your
hidden layer which are sort of your
quasi particles and if this hidden layer
is smaller then this is a way for you to
zoom out right to reduce the complexity
of your description and you do the same
thing you you try to train that in a way
that's sort of macroscopic properties
don't change too much they always change
a little but you try to minimize that
change so you can use those by stacking
them on top of each other I guess most
people probably have seen this and if
you if you encode this and decode this
you'll see that you end up with a
slightly blurry version of of your
original picture so the takeaway here is
that what physics teaches us is we have
descriptions at different scales
relevant fields irrelevant fields and
our RG steps and those in machine
learning would correspond to features
noise and compression respectively so
why what one one thing that this can
also kind of help us kind of answer why
do physical theories look so simple so
if you look at normalization
this is something I'm not going to prove
because it's not simple at all but it
turns out that very very complicated
terms that involve a lot of different
particles interacting with each other
have the tendency to become more
irrelevant so there's in physics there's
there's a tendency for simplicity there
and the what I the suspicion would be
that's maybe in machine learning or like
in the real world let's say things that
we care about tend to have that same
property that's not very exact I mean
yeah what what does that buy us right
this doesn't tell us like why theories
learned so well etc so we want to have
something more tangible so let's move to
something tangible convolutional neural
networks these are extremely successful
at modeling image data so let's look a
little bit I'll go over it really fast
so let's say you have some stack of
images and every image have like the
pixels of those images can take
different values let's say maybe like
RGB or something like different
different colors so you have your image
data as a multi-dimensional array so you
have you know all the all the spatial
pixels and then you have also all the
values that those pixels can take and
the important thing here is that we
don't like in a normal neural network
immediately roll out all the values as
one big factor we want to sort of
conserve the spatial information of what
is near each other so this is what one
of those whole networks looks like and
you know you you start with your inputs
you do a convolution which I'll explain
pooling which is basically reducing your
number of degrees of freedom and you can
do that many times and at some point all
the way at the end you do flatten it out
like a normal neural network I call that
the fully connected layer and that's
where you learn you're where you
actually try to like learn your your
targets
so let's go over it a little bit I'm
assuming most people have seen it but
why not it's useful to have it sort of
fresh in our minds so we have this input
layer D would be the the sort of the
dimension of the pixels number of values
that intake has a height and a width and
what we use is a kernel or a filter it's
the same thing just different names and
which is smaller but it has the same
number of dimensions so every so every
the way we do this we have multiple of
these filters we can have one or more
whatever we want and they we start with
a field of vision we start by taking
apart a localized part of our image so
that's where there's sort of the
locality the locality of our input
pixels comes into play and we take the
inner product and after that some
activation function relu is a very
popular one it's nonlinear it learns
very fast and you you need something
nonlinear and basically you move your
field of vision so every so every so
every every one of those convolutional
operators is basically you have your
chunk of input data you have your filter
it sort of goes through the filter and
you get a one pixel value like one node
value so you move through it so there's
a parameter it's like the stride so how
fast it moves through it's like how many
does it's like sensor over every pixel
or not if you don't then of course you
reduce your parameter space a bit more
quickly and you go over the end maybe
you apply another filter maybe you apply
many of them so the number of filters
that you apply determines the dimension
of your second of your second data layer
let's say so you've you've ended up with
probably a smaller number of
of let's say quasi pixels in your second
in your in your in your second datasets
but it may not be drastically less and
you can have a different number of
filters it can be more or or less
whatever so after that if you want to
reduce the complexity or you want to
reduce sort of the number of parameters
then you can do pooling which is you
take each of these blocks and you just
map them to one pixel you can do that
may be average max pooling max pooling
is very popular I'm not really going to
go much into that but that's really a
quick way of drastically reducing your
size if you do max pooling the nice
thing is you can just if you remember
like which index was the maximum one
then you only need to back propagate
through those maximum sort of channels
so that's nice so this is relu and max
pooling is sort of the very very popular
standard convolutional network so the
activation function is nonlinear so
basically the the transformation you do
on your on your nodes after your
convolution is nonlinear and you use max
pooling another type of network that is
not as well known quite promising but
for our purposes much more useful is the
convolutional arithmetic circuit so the
activations are linear and the way it's
nonlinear is through product pooling so
instead of taking the max or taking the
average it has a it takes the products
of all the of all the nodes in the
pooling step so this brings us to sensor
networks so I'm this is kind of a side
step I'm gonna take I'm gonna first go
over a little bit of like very very
basics not really tensor algebra but
like something similar just just for you
to like follow along a little bit with
that so if you can you can think of a
tensor as a multi-dimensional
it can be you can represent the tensor
by multi-dimensional array it's not
exactly the same thing
but I guess multi-dimensional array flow
doesn't sound like a sketchy-ass tensor
flow so let's just use the word tensor
and you get a scalar is a tensor of
degree zero you can have a vector which
has like one dangling edge that's that's
how I'll use the notation or one index
if if I use if you see the bottom that's
that's how I would use it in an equation
matrix will have two dangling edges or
two indices in each of those indices
will have some kind of dimension right
like the number of values it can take or
you can have like a degree and tensor
where you see like a whole number of
these dangling edges and most of these
things you don't really need to know but
just to give you an idea a dot product
between two vectors you can write it of
course as in the right but you can also
write it in this pictorial
representation as the two dangling edges
of a vector connecting together being
summed over the closed edge basically
means you're summing over that and you
get a scalar out and you can matrix
product with a vector of course and a
matrix trace also ends you like leaves
you with a scalar and there's also the
opposite where you for example create a
matrix out of two vectors by taking a
tensor product you don't really need to
know much about that or you can do
something like SVD where you split a
matrix into multiple constituents and
the nice thing here is with SVD you can
do it exact but you can also start
dropping out some of the smaller
singular values and sort of approximate
get an approximate value of your matrix
that way that's something that could be
useful later that idea that you can you
can get maybe not an exact
representation by splitting it but maybe
you can get an
with representation by reducing the
number the dimension of the bonds the
closed months in between so let's go
back to our convolutional layer and try
to view that as a tensor operator so we
have our field of vision we have all
those filters that we want to apply to
them so let's start with the first
filter let's so what we've done is we've
taken that field of vision and we've
taken that filter now we unroll it into
effect into a vector and take adult
products so we end up here with just one
node and we do that with all the other
filters we end up with an array of them
so let's just say that this is a matrix
of those filters and then we take a
product between our input vector and
that matrix and let's do that for all
the for all the fields of vision we have
so these X the X's are basically all the
fields of vision that we could possibly
have as we are moving over our image so
those are all the environments like the
the little patches so one thing to note
is that after this operation so this
takes basically our number of values
that our pixels could have and it took a
dot product so basically we don't have
that dimension anymore but it does it
like D prime times it does it's the
number of filters times so you're
changing your you're changing your
dimension from D to D prime here so in
the pooling layer remember we just we
just took a max or an average or
something of those or a product of all
the input pixels and so you can take any
number of them here I just took two but
it could be more so you have I'm calling
this a triangle just to to make it
visually sort of more different from
from the other nodes
so you can take any any shots of any
number of nodes and you do your fooling
operator and you get one node out and
important to note here is that here the
dimension actually doesn't change
so this pooling happens layer by layer
so every filter that you have or let's
say every color or whatever you do a
separate pooling step for that so that
actually doesn't change so let's put it
together there are many ways that you
can build a tent that you can build the
convolutional arithmetic circuit as a
tensor network this is a very deep way
you could make it very shallow basically
have only one convolutional layer and
then have basically everything collect
in one big pooling layer just take big
product of everything and that would be
a shallow Network and probably not very
good for learning so but what yeah so
let's look a little bit at the elements
here so on the bottom you'll see the
input regions and the the other round
bits those are the convolutional weights
then we have all the triangles are all
the pooling all the pooling steps and
then all those little d these are the
bomb dimensions so what we can use this
for so the I haven't basically proved to
you that this is actually a tensor
Network the paper below their dust do
the proof it would be probably a little
bit too too long to try that here but
what this buys us that you can view this
as a tensor Network is that a tensor
network is actually something from from
physics if we have all these little
particles that that have like some
number of some number of states that
they can be in and we want to describe
how a collection of them behave and
normally you can
view them as independent particles so if
the right-hand side were true that would
basically be their sort of a product of
each other their independence but in in
reality normally that isn't the case so
normally you have just some really big
complicated function of all of them and
and you you cannot really solve them
separately so the way in physics that is
dealt with is well one way is using
tensor networks where the choice of the
tensor network is sort of sort of tries
to use information about entanglements
between these particles because
entanglement is in a way how much it is
not true how much this equation is not
true how much it's not sort of
independence how much they are not
independent particles so depending on
how much entangled they are and whether
different regions are entangled with
each other or not you would choose a
different tensor network and this we can
this this this is exactly the same if we
can view our convolutional circuits as a
tensor network we can we can use sort of
the same kind of reasoning about
entanglement in particular we will say
for example if we have if we split our
image into two input regions like this
the blue and the orange part we can we
can choose and try to choose a network
that would handle let's say entanglement
between that well and basically the way
you do that is by looking at the
smallest bond dimension the smallest
number of collection of bonds that you
would have to cut in order to to make
them disconnected from each other
and that's basically your bottleneck
that's your bottleneck of how well you
can measure entanglement between the two
and those papers below tell you how and
why so I would definitely recommend you
like look into that if you find that
interesting similarly you could look at
different entanglement patterns maybe
you're interested in how local regions
are how local regions can be modeled if
they're correlated with each other and
then you would look at a smaller
different different cuts that you would
have to make so um that was it thank you
and there's a github page with a little
bit of sort of popular science but also
other reading about all the things that
I've talked about and there's a few
things that I didn't cover that I'm
linking to there as well
there is a Python library actually that
you can use it's a it's called tensor
like just tensor network its bills on
top of tensor flow so I definitely
recommend play around with that and I'll
take any questions questions so I wonder
what's a use case of the UM sensor
networking your company none yeah sorry
so we do computer vision I do not
personally we have computer vision
engineers we use out of the box models
and yeah so so at our current company we
do not work in this at all this is
weekend work I don't have a life
[Laughter]
most importantly does your farm grow
that fractal broccoli we definitely
shoot so yeah we definitely should where
we're currently we're quite young when I
joined our farm was still literally
under construction with software
engineers and like our cats we are
working on fruiting crops now but but I
think fractal fractals is an underserved
market I agree on a more serious note so
I've heard those who said o our deep
neural networks are problem solved we
just gotta keep feeding it more data so
right now the self-driving car does know
what to do if someone's trying to land a
plane on the highway but just give it
that a couple examples of that we'll be
good to go and others that said that
fundamentally this problem is too hard
for the state of the art right now any
thoughts from the physics perspective
what kinds of problems are set for this
and what aren't that's an excellent
question so I mean the problems that are
already solved they they're already
they're already solved because you
already have like a pretty good
intuition about it so the the sort of
the thinkers already got really far with
that with other things well you could
say things that are currently not widely
studied but where you might have an
intuition we're sort of correlations
between regions mites or between areas
might make sense but I think I think in
those cases you probably would already
map it to something you already know
right so you probably why a lot of
things like sound analysis you can map
that to an image and sort of solve that
so given that I don't spend my days
working on deep learning problems I
don't have a great answer for you there
but I think I think most of the problems
where it would be directly where where
this sort of knowledge will be useful
would probably be something that you can
map to something you understand better I
should imagine
we have time for one more question right
here can you go into a little more depth
on sort of the the connection you are
making to like the renormalization group
so like I don't have a great
understanding of what it is but I
imagine it as some sort of way tensor
quantities whose like the transformation
laws that sort of define a tensor will
allow to sort of like encode things
about like varying scales and something
like that or something like that so I
can you just go um
say a little bit more about sort of the
nature of that of that connection with
the renormalization right
I see yeah so the parallel is that in
the renormalization group what you try
to minimise is between two descriptions
the difference in free energy of those
descriptions and and in case of the in
case of machine learning it would be
something equivalent Kubik Leibler
divergence so your so you're in a sense
you're you're you're trying to find
you're trying to find a more
coarse-grained description that that
satisfies something that you want to
keep constants asked like s constant as
you can which would be something that
gives you like macroscopic microscopic
properties of your of your system not
really sure if I answer to your question
there okay yeah so that was a that's why
I stressed it's an unsupervised
it's unsupervised right so basically in
in physics you say well physics doesn't
change right macroscopic like a magnet
is not something not suddenly not a
magnet anymore just because you're
putting on blurry glasses but you have
something similar in machine learning
where you say sort of yeah let's thank
our speaker one more time
[Applause]